a lawyer for Donald Trump and founder of
Biddle Law Group joins me now from
Virginia good to see you on he's
certainly keeping you lawyers busy isn't
he what have the many cases he's facing
are you directly working on then
so I'm not working on either of those
cases at all
um I I represent him on on other matters
um although of course these are are
important cases not only for president
Trump but for Americans uh everywhere is
we kind of fight for the rule of law in
our country right now and against the
politicalization of our judicial system
okay let's talk about today shall we
first of all the appearance via video
link in the Fallout from the Stormy
Daniels payments and a trial date set
March the 25th 2024 slap bang as you
know in the critical Republican primary
phase
um no wonder he was uh shaking his head
vigorously when he heard that date
well yeah I think that's absolutely
right and that
um just shows that unfortunately we have
a court system in New York that is not
currently politically neutral
um I really wish in America right now we
had the political neutral Judiciary that
that britons quite frankly are are
blessed with
um that that we just really don't have
at the moment and you see a Judiciary in
New York a prosecution system in New
York that's trying to interfere with the
2024 uh Republican presidential election
they know that they can't beat Donald
Trump at The Ballot Box so instead
they're trying to prosecute him this is
a very very dangerous time in America
okay well let's let's examine the
evidence specifically on this one then
did he pay off Stormy Daniels and were
business records falsified in order to
pay her off
and more importantly legally speaking
um is that is that a crime is having a
non-disclosure agreement a crime is it a
violation of federal campaign Finance
law because his entire case falls apart
unless it's a violation of federal
campaign Finance law and it's not
um federal election Commissioners Uh
current and former have written about
the fact that these allegations do not
amount to a a federal campaign Finance
violation
um even if what it is is true and
remember that the factual basis for
these uh claims are from Michael Cohen
who has pled guilty and and pled and
already admitted to being a liar
admitted to uh false statement charges
in federal court and has done prison
time for at the behest of Donald Trump I
mean I've read his book twice to be fair
and the question is did what was the
payments from Stormy Daniels whether
they paid off via Michael Cohen and was
that effectively illegal now you're
saying well is any of it illegal that is
for the court to decide but it does not
mean looking at the process of this that
it's trying to you know change the
result of the 2024 U.S election does it
now that's actually what I absolutely
disagree with because when you take
something where people on the right and
the left have have agreed that there's
just no there there in these uh charges
and then you have a a prosecutor
um who has openly campaigned in favor of
Prosecuting Donald Trump
um and then it does it does does it and
does it in such a way that it interferes
with the 2024 election you put a
criminal trial right in the middle of a
primary when almost all legal observers
say that there's absolutely no legal
basis for these charges it unfortunately
does show that the process itself is the
punishment that regardless of whether or
not he's ever convicted just by putting
him through this process is an attempt
to influence politics not to enforce
criminal laws and that's the problem but
what the problem is it's not the only
case he faces is it we're still waiting
to see about Georgia the idea of
election tampering there we've all heard
about Eugene Carroll which I'll come on
to in a minute the New York case as well
with the allegation that he inflated his
profits in his business Empire in order
to raise debt and deflated them in order
to pay lower taxes I mean we when we
mentioned classified documents it's one
thing after another I go back to the
date of this court case over the Stormy
Daniels Fallout right slap bang in
primary primary season he can't carry on
can he um as a candidate in this
election and still focus on all of these
court cases
and that is the point is that I mean
first of all he can and he will there's
nobody tougher than Donald Trump that
can that can walk and chew gum at the
same time if you will so yes he will but
that is the point you have unfortunately
left-wing prosecutors left-wing uh
Department of Justice Personnel who are
engaged in in what we're calling lawfare
and that is law not with the attempt to
win in a courtroom but but in order to
score political points and they're doing
it in court
um where they think that Donald Trump
will not get a fair trial both from
judges in in courts that are very
anti-trump and have made very anti-trump
comments
um from the bench and in their personal
lives you know for instance the judge in
the uh criminal case in New York donated
to vote to Joe Biden donated to Trump's
political rival and hasn't recused
himself from the case that's something
that quite frankly would never happen in
the UK
um and uh then you you look at all these
these attempts to try to defeat Donald
Trump in the courtroom because they
can't do it at The Ballot Box
Eugene Carroll obviously a victory for
her in her sexual assault allegations
against Donald Trump seeking further
defamation uh damage payments now
because he called her a whack job he
claimed the trial was rigged he said
she'd made up a story about him all in a
CNN Town Hall soon after the trial um
the court in the Stormy Daniels Fallout
is genuinely concerned about what he
will disclose what advice you're giving
him because you know loose tongues you
know prompt penalties don't they in the
court system
well and I of course can't go into to
any details that I would give a client
but I don't represent him in that matter
and so what I'll say is that
um you can't uh Donald Trump isn't going
to be silenced he's he's not going to be
bullied
um so he's suggesting that if he gets to
close your documents uh in the Stormy
Daniels case he would disclose them but
he is part of his campaigning is that
what he would do
well I mean right now one of the biggest
issues in America is the
politicalization of our justice system
and he's going to campaign on that
um to assume that he's going to release
documents I I think is wrong but uh if
it's an attempt by the court to try to
shut him up so he won't talk about this
case which is I think the biggest uh
issue facing Americans right now
um it's not going to work and to be
quite honest the reason that we have the
first amendment in this country goes
back to uh the American war for
independence the the little dispute that
our countries had once upon a time
um where the biggest issue was something
called prior restraints on speech where
uh the British government would impose
on the American colonists uh a
injunction against them speaking on
political topics and that was the number
one issue that the founders of the
American Constitution wanted to fight
back against make sure that never
happened and this injunction against
President Trump speaking the leading
candidate by far for the Republican
nomination for for president flies
directly in the face of the First
Amendment of the United States
Constitution and quite frankly is
there's no way it's going to stand no I
understand you know the importance of
free speech no doubt about it but you
know those against Donald Trump would
say first of all the allegations that
the 2020 election were were rigged were
wrong the allegations the Eugene Carroll
case were rigged were wrong your
allegations that this future case is
going to be rigged or is politicizing
the US court system is wrong and at best
delusional
oh absolutely not I mean everything that
you just said is is actually
um inaccurate so you still say the 2020
election was rigged I I'm saying that
there were major problems with the the
20 uh 20 election that were that were
documented major problems calling up
Georgia trying to get them to change
their vote Ali
um the the issue in in Georgia it was as
the president said the president's
called it a a per a perfect phone call
and any objective person do you think it
was a person well as a lawyer genuinely
do you yeah absolutely because what the
president was talking about on that
phone call is that there were hundreds
of thousands of disputed votes and and
the president was pointing out you don't
have to go fight to to get a hundred
thousand or two hundred thousand votes
change the difference in the election
was eleven thousand so we just have to
prove that there was 11 000 improper
votes that's what president Trump meant
everybody understands that's what
president Trump meant and that's
something
um again protected by by the First
Amendment protected by other aspects of
the United States Constitution I think
that it'd be Preposterous of if this
district attorney actually brought
charges on that quite frankly I think
that if she does charge anything it's
not going to be that but whatever
charges she brings
um regarding the the election
um is is truly dangerous for freedom of
speech and for political freedom in the
United States and I think it's very
unlikely
um that uh those charges are are going
to stand if she does try to bring him
Donald Trump he must be tired by all of
this I mean why not you know he's in his
70s why not just sort of retire and uh
you know slink away from all of this
because it's exhausting isn't it it must
be exhausting for all of you and his
legal team
uh you know it is certainly
um
um an exhausting process to put up with
everything that's out there but let me
tell you something it's much more so for
us us lawyers than Donald Trump I've
never seen anybody with the energy and
the passion for the American people that
Donald Trump has and he simply is not
going to be uh be silenced and he's not
going to just lay back and quit and say
I just got to focus on these these legal
cases he knows that these legal cases
are all an attempt to try to to get him
out of the race to get him out of the
picture and I've never seen him slow
down I've never seen it uh do these
cases do anything other than fire him up
even more this is a passionate man he's
passionate about these issues for the
American people and in the end I'm
confident he's going to win
lawyer there for Donald Trump
fascinating to hear your thoughts there
uh founder of binal Law Group joining us
from Virginia I hope you'll talk to us
again
um thank you very much indeed thank you
I hope so was a pleasure thank you